today we're finishing looking at the
normal distribution I would love you
even though you've drawn many of them
under today's handing please draw
another normal distribution because what
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you how to tackle some of these trickier
questions that are some of you asked me
at the Midway or at the end of last
lesson because what's the job you get up
to it and some of you did but most of
you did it so I saw want to show you how
they work and you'll need a normal
distribution and your page reader is
playing so on this lower distribution
the most important part of the graph is
right there smack bang in the middle
because we know for the normal
distribution there are three measures of
central tendency and they're all the
same value
what are those three again me mode and
median they're all right here on the
center
we're just mark them all as me and we
know that the big concept behind the
normal distribution is if you know where
the mean is and then you know what this
will you calculate rather the standard
deviation of your set of scores then as
you go once their deviation two standard
deviations three standard deviations
away you can have a very good sense of
how much of the population you have
within that range okay so a lot maybe if
you don't
colors inflation bipolar let's draw in
our one two three standard deviations
away from convene so I'm just gonna
combine it roughly like this now what
we've got here is from the main I've
color-coded one two and three standard
deviations away from me
so you might met by the unit this is
plus one standard deviation and this is
minus one continue going further
you've got plus 2 and minus 2 and then
lastly as far as we're willing to go
you've got plus three - okay now I want
you to recall we said if you are within
this certain range and you say one two
or three standing agents we've got all
of these numbers for working on it of
how much of the population is within
seven families so for instance here
within one standard deviation of the
mean just by the shape of the graph you
can see you've got a huge proportion of
people in their shapes so this orange
portion of the ground in here do you
remember what the percentage was 60
68% of the population well over half
offers wealth more than two-thirds is in
that little bit if we go down to
standard deviations
I don't this far how much of the
population to be at this time 95 very
good
so that 95 yeah I'll come to that one
that 95 obviously includes the 68 we
already mentioned and then the last one
that we go out go as Margie this is the
99.7 for economics
okay so let's look at two different
kinds of questions that take these
simple ideas and apply them its own
slightly unusual so I'm just going to
finish out coloring a little bit
[Music]
now I really hope well I know for a fact
actually that some of you have recounted
some of the questions that I'm about to
show you on the board if you're like oh
yeah I remember this I'm fine with this
you're more than welcome to continue on
but most of you at least last time
hadn't gotten up to this point so here's
a question that they might posed is the
actual reading um what percentage of a
population in a normal distribution what
percentage you to the population and
then they'll provide you a range of
z-scores so we might say prisoners what
does it ensure the population has a
z-score between say negative one and two
question mark so when you have a look at
this we know that standard different
sorry standard scores Zed scores are
about how many of these are away so I
want you to have a look at the ground
the distribution and where these things
belong okay so negative one do you see
that this guy over here right
all of these people of this line have a
z-score of negative one
what about to is to yeah it's great
light over here right so the question is
asking how much of this population is in
this boundary here does that make sense
now when you look at the picture and the
picture is so important in fact um the
first thing I would do when I get a page
which has this in it and this being a
sensitive topic is that you see on the
form of - a what all of these numbers
are right but actually it's the picture
that will help you to move so just like
even if it's literally on your formula -
a or somewhat ready to just draw this
thing needs to be smaller just so you
can get the picture can you see that
obviously but we know you wanted to
includes this whole orange section of do
training like it's got at least sixty
eight passivity and then it's got a bit
more okay so my answer to this is going
to be 68% plus whatever this little star
spirit does that make sense
I've got orange plus half of the green
so then the question becomes how do I
work out how much is in that one little
green area does anyone want to suggest I
might go out doing this everything
okay fantastic so remember we're saying
each of these as we go out further
includes all the previous things in it
right so we move on to the workout just
this little sliver I've got to say this
entire green area and orange area is 95
percent okay so maybe what you want to
put down is you can add such a diagram
if you want that if you include both of
the green exclusively great areas right
then there must be 95 takeaways 68 do
you Road that that's the part that I've
taken down so if that's 95 takeaways 68
percent don't tell me that is 27 so
therefore 27 includes both of these
signs so each one of these individually
is going to be half of that which looks
to me like thirteen and a half percent
that make sense so therefore my answer
to this question is going to be
percentage equals
so I'm going to first I'm going to say
the 68 that's the Orangemen and then I'm
gonna add on the 13.5 just puffing it
does that make sense you see where I got
it from so you could say well what is
that eighty eighty one point five yeah
there we go okay so that's not too
difficult for Hyper you can ask for
eighty range of different Zen scores and
you can work out in exactly the same way
we did with a bit of subtraction
sometimes you have to have things you
can work out any percentage of the
population that is within a certain
range so forth yeah correct so what I've
got is if this is one standard deviation
away and this is two that don't bring in
both directions that push outwards is
27% that's a difference between those
two things right but if I only want one
half of it that's why I try this by two
to get that does that make sense
correct that's right I mean there's no
reason why you can't keep on going
normal standard deviations away but if
you think about it these people on these
ends like even further than three they
are so exceptional that they'd happen so
rarely we don't really have any reliable
information about them well we do have
reliable information that is right here
the sizes